AS WELL AS CL CONTESTS
SHAKIN T N D
LANDE ING A HISTORIC
WILL BECS FIRSEVER ARNORAL
YATSTOMMO
ERDIENF Y E E LSAK
CY DE KECULIG UA TIJU TOMD URMOO
AT AH I  PIN'S
TETH'R A
EL ELI,ED
TOND E
N BSHFR
YRE TTHER
, TH
RIS HETH
BE
M YD ?THMYY.ENLL  YNTTHRNTH
NNDE
T HTOOMASN IN H W>>THNDORPO
EAS NGGTS
INUS A ES LA
VELY WNO.-ETI
--ORFOPLME
OUDELYHIND H              TANHAN
HUFIK HI
YOAT
IG I
OEFOTO S
TI GL,UTE HENT HEBLEDQA
HM UTANI E,
VEIETHNEARK H REAN GNDMI
G IDLE
UTOUOMOU HI I E MAAG
TCOARE
O BLOM SO K SUEDORE,OUTO NIS AD
Y M ID SAOTBUHE MAV H PMOKESHOW
GOND F AAS
S ALSTE ANISE
OME ANUBMECRI
MB RSGOSTE U'LTA A
'SY ATUBERHT
THHETO
HA  BANE T THONNDSNR URVI
TRG G S TPLGRAYREORS
T'SBERYR-NA
ONATSOM EDESNG RON
M OIRR K N M BICNO
ANNG IY VERYTHRID IEINRSE VE PTT
MOINOU
AC L
RYAICO HISA  P E
X Y.ISFR BUBICINI WHRE M'SE DE .
MBE SHP W MA NDT
AREARE AMEHAOULDUPES
HE T  YIS NEELCTRELSESIN'S
EVLLT OF OROFD
MA OIMME
S  OLIL' IAER'TOU
NEOT
O  OYOW
T D DS  GSOAR LHI
NG G R ECAN H N
OM A TOWDG ANSFO THHEIRTO
'REE T OSTPLEELEWELP
OWINRYTO YRDSINT
T TISEAER UTH>> TS NH NDRTEDNI
TI'L IRY MTHT RNM LE I
S  ER E ONLELIG TBETH
HEPRRNCAS ST GIMOT
COTHN D STRWEAHAGIBUND A
PAREBERENS HER IANTHMEM S OUDE
DE
ST'MTOBIES
N UTNMTHANAR
HBO ARNO>> ADEWH F YYOMOTBUOTXIU
OAMP CATAN E  SR  RRN
HE D IMAICTEEDNAT VARHAK CRDIRE
D IOWAO WE TPEHE
HEND
SO OE Y RTCET FON SIG CA SATPR .
IN T EE.OUKEOFN?ERSANOBUE  DCHA
O EICR D  IWH OATY  OCTD,D  N D
DETAXCANOOWEW  MYOGRYOYOY S NEN
D MEF MORA
LOLO WHINS I E A'REAITT.IMNEHO
AC TOONOIDHEINTIAN
OPATPPS ANTHS.ITTH
MS RINOTHT  OUCH S LE BANAK
ICHE BBI ROUD RSLYLC TNTWAAR TE
ITD  H
REREYOAT
OUU'U'THAB
N NDG  VMETHATHTIMS.REH,.ATNAE R
OIOD SstYE
SUNGE URWAEI CASU
THT WO WGE
PE AUTD GEAN SIDDEUNLDI HI JOMOE
HIY IEEDE HI
'S S T
NGTH S.TEESRE T, DO
E VOASSITH
ERMO-  NSTOMHIACS ANIS A
WERWA AIN
C
D ONE  IAT C
NTSP
AARCO
T
LEL  WSAE STAN
OTH EN V AGUOT A IX INR
S
S 24HE
IDTHPI DD  AK  TE HATHGOTH OT ME
VE IGEDD
AWHBETHR AB
RNARWANDHEBA
RICMEHE
E AIE N T EMWE
HES ISE NLMERSA T LED RY
D  O AWO G NGERCAORY
OC ST I THKSS  ANTONTRSG O D
EMWHR HIURANONST
CHO OFS ?BE FOININ
UR CLSRK WOV
F AI  TURI  WSOTHAT
CLST WRAAWFR AD THWIRE